dieses bild wird zum symbol polnische
frauen lassen sich nicht einschüchtern
von der übermacht der staatsgewalt eine
kleine frau und ziemlich viele
polizisten die wollen ihre personalien
aufnehmen und verlieren die geduld
wir möchten sie ihn mit wem wir sprechen
warum es herrn sie an mir ich habe schon
gesorgt aber nein
lassen sie mich einfach los können sie
mich los lassen dann zappeln sie nicht
können sie nicht normal
aus welchem verdammten grund später
nehmen sie die personalien auf und
lassen sie geht über soziale medien
haben wir sie ausfindig gemacht sofia 29
tier medizinstudentin gläubige
katholikin die für das recht auf
abtreibung ist die kirche solle sich bei
der entscheidung von frauen raushalten
vom polizeieinsatz ist sie bis heute
schockiert
ich hatte angst dass sie mich
irgendwohin weg bringen das ist die
wahrheit
wenn ich mit dem polizisten auf die
andere seite gehe sie mich ins auto
packen und man weiß nicht für wie lange
und wo hin was im auto geschieht kann
man nicht beweisen
sofia ist keine aktivistin aber dass das
verfassungsgericht strammen auf
regierungslinie das strenge
abtreibungsrecht noch verschärft hat
empört sie sie fordert freie gerichte
die seit der justizreform in gefahr sind
als man am anfang sagte die justizreform
wird solche folgen haben die wir gerade
erleben schien mir das unglaublich ich
sagte mir damals unmöglich wir leben
doch im 21 jahrhundert seit sechs wochen
gehen vor allem junge frauen auf die
straße im ganzen land zunächst weiß ein
aufschrei gegen das abtreibungsrecht
mittlerweile machen sich jahre des frust
luft
die regierungspartei kies baut mit ihrem
konservativen kirchen am kurs das land
schritt für schritt um die
demonstrantinnen aber wollen ein
liberales polen europafreundlich
tolerant viele bringen ihre kinder mit
wie router für sie geht es um die
zukunft ihrer töchter
sie ist eine kleine frau die
möglicherweise bald auch vor einer
schweren entscheidung steht und ich will
dass es ihre und nur ihre entscheidung
ist und nicht die der männer in
schwarzen anzügen oder priester kleidung
dieses thema abtreibung macht die frau
zum objekt das ist mehr als die hälfte
der polnischen gesellschaft die
plötzlich ein grundlegendes recht
verliert über die entscheidung über den
eigenen körper ein ganz anderes noch
konservativeres polen will carla goldeck
der kopf von polens abtreibungsgegner
sie und ihre mitstreiter sind gekommen
fiebern der verkündung des abtreibungs
entgegen und polens verfassungsgericht
liefert entscheidet am 22 oktober im
sinne der pis abtreibung bei schwerer
missbildungen des fötus wird verbunden
das urteil ist ihr triumph mehrfach
waren kaya kodex ultra-konservative mit
einer verschärfung des abtreibungsrechts
gescheitert jedes mal haben wir gehört
wenn die initiative abgelehnt wurde dass
euer kampf keinen sinn macht geht nach
hause
das wird nichts in keinem anderen land
der welt ist so was nun passiert heute
ist polen ein beispiel für europa und
die welt carius anhänger akzeptieren nur
die konservative katholische familie in
der abtreibungsdebatte zeigt sich wie im
brennglas dass polen der zwei will
dennoch das sind polnische familien sie
haben es satt dass sich
ultrakonservative wie kaya goldeck die
deutungshoheit über familie und
patriotismus zu sprechen
sonntagsspaziergang der zum protest wird
für ein säkulares polen für einen bunten
offenen familienbegriff viele regenbogen
flaggen
wir sind dagegen dass man uns
vorschreibt ob eine familie vollständig
oder nicht sein sollte katholisch oder
nicht ob homosexuelle personen in der
familie sein können oder nicht wir
finden die definition einzugrenzen ist
das resultat von fanatismus von
irgendwelchen ängsten polens
polarisierung zeigt sich auch im
parlament im saal gehen
oppositionsabgeordnete auf die barrikade
richtet sich vor allem gegen ihn
jaroslaw kaczynski
das ist krieg rufen sie ihm zu die im
parteichef und übervater der
nationalkonservativen pis
sicherheitskräfte ziehen auf beiden
seiten spitzt sich die ohnehin schon
scharfe rhetorik zu bei einer anderen
sitzung skandiert die opposition du
wirst ins gefängnis die
wenn in polen endlich ein rechtsstaat
ist werden einige von euch einsetzen
[Applaus]
polens nationalisten fühlen sich
bestärkt am nationalfeiertag marschieren
sie auf gegen abtreibung für gott ehre
vaterland feuerwerkskörper fliegen auf
balkone mit protestplakaten und lgb
tieflage lasst die [ __ ] brennen hört man
im twitter wie die ihre feindbilder sind
sie polens liberale frauen wie sophia
wieder auf der straße eine gläubige
katholiken die doch das erzkonservative
narrativ von regierung und kirche nicht
mehr hören will
ich handle unter dem einfluss von
emotionen ich fühle keine angst es ist
mir klar dass die situation gefährlich
ist aber ich finde ich sollte das tun es
ist meine pflicht
wie lange haben sie noch vor zu
protestieren
solange wie es sein muss so lange wie es
sein muss eine neue generation mit polen
auf recht auf abtreibung freie gerichte
liberale werte dieses junge polen hat
die pis wohl für immer verloren
[Musik]